et hop
laurent gayraud passe à richard astre
qui passe informations qui passent à
casimir qui déborde magnifiquement tous
ses adversaires et bien marqué par ce
plan guide et c'est toi
eh ben dis donc qu'elle est c'est
quasiment toutes mes félicitations mon
dieu merci merci mes amis merci je
m'entraîne pour le match de demain
bon tu un match de rugby demain oui un
match très difficile
alors il faut que je froid dans une
super forme je comprends tu dis moi tu
as tout ton équipement pour l'équipement
cas quel équipement sa casimir si tu
n'as pas d'équipement pour jouer comment
vas tu faire alors je n'y ai pas pensé
il faut un équipement
il faut beaucoup de choses tout d'abord
casimiri toutefois un ballo police et ça
je le sais mais on n'a pas besoin
d'apporter un ballon chacun
ça ça tu as raison et ensuite bien
coindreau un maillot il te faut une
culotte une paire de chaussettes et une
paire de chaussures quand la rame et il
faut tout ça absolument mais connaît des
changements indispensables pour un jour
de répondre mais je n'ai rien du tout
pour moi j'ai une idée pris ma malle
magique va me sortir de cette situation
tu vas voir les enfants
apportez moi un moment magique la
toussaint elle est formidable et
j'espère on va voir ça pour la kenya il
en grade il voudrait garder les enfants
avec nous et il pourrait t'aider mais
j'ai ma malle magique pour ça le meti et
casimir tamales magique qu'elle est un
type comme toi elle ne donne pas
toujours la bonne réponse tu prends
vraiment j'en suis certain bon on va
voir bon attention petite malle magique
donne moi un ballon de rugby
ballon de rugby c'est un ballon de rugby
ça les enfants pascale qu'est ce que
c'est delhomme foot c'est un ballon de
football
autre chose casimir bon alors un ballon
de rugby
voilà c'est ça est un ballon de rugby va
effectivement casimir leur bon je le
mets de côté
jusque là je lui demande maintenant un
maillot un maillot folio m petite malle
magique de noir un maillot de rugby un
maillot de rugby pour casimir petite
malle magique c'est ça qu'est ce que
c'est que ça c'est un maillot de rugby
ça qu'est ce que c'est
c'est à une orgie de tennis de tennis
chemisette de tennis on n'a pas besoin
ça qu'est ce que c'est c'est un pull de
marins casimir ce n'est pas la faire je
suis désolé alors voilà voyons ça qu'est
ce que c'est que ça c'était une douceur
de quel sport c'est un maillot vie pour
faire la course à pied avec le numéro du
concurrent ça c'était le maillot de
monsieur du snob
oui quand kazimierz et me voilà lé pour
faire du ski on n'en restera pas là
casimir casimir maintenant soyons
sérieux ça qu'est ce que ce bien voilà
voilà
mais pour le rugby on vole un meilleur
rugby casimir c'est bien alors qu elle
mettait et bien maintenant tu vas me
donner une culotte et new deal à une
culotte d'une ville de rigaud les images
magiques voilà le cheval ou une culotte
de cheval à effet miroir c'est ne rien
avoir
voilà alors
bruno dans la cage à poules cette
chambre de footballeur ah oui oui à la
faire non plus voilà le maillot de rugby
des pantalons de rugby très bien fabrice
et bruno c'est d'une culotte en
plastique pour bébé casimir sérieux tu
pourrais rentrer dans une petite culotte
comme ça hein
c'est un vol aller se trompe parfois
c'est peut-être ça alors voyons c'est ça
oui oui oui ça c'est le genre de rugby
qui ont mis rejetant est prêt
voilà qu'est ce qu'on lui demande
maintenant et bien les chaussettes les
chaussettes les chairs de chaussettes
les chaussettes de rugby voilà te vois
en train de jouer au rugby avec des
chaussettes comme ça pas tellement mais
on sait jamais au sérieux casimir dont
ces sédiments baissier magie voilà
j'avais raison c'est peut-être ça quelle
est la différence parce qu'elle émet oui
mais oui ce sont des chaussettes pour
ajouté ce qu'on attend
j'en ai d'autres large est-ce que ça va
ça ça fait la faire oui mais je vais la
faire sauter la terre pour le rugby on
aime bien sûr les retraités qu'est ce
qu'on a oublié françois même agence une
paire de chaussures oui qu'il faut sur
petite malle magique donne moi des
chaussures d'un rugby de fait ce que
c'est que ça
fabien robert et bruno se marre de
footballeur à se trompent pas ça ce sont
des chaussures de tennis
ouais ensuite hop c'est ça que 5,5 et
pourquoi l'a très bien dit d'accord ce
sont des chaussures de course à pied de
course à pied alors petite marge à il a
répondu qu'une paire c'est ça oui ce
sont des chaussures avec des chaussures
de rugby le casimir dû à tout
l'équipement d'un joueur de rugby le
meiyo le ballon les chaussettes la
culotte et les chaussures dont les émirs
heureusement que les enfants étaient là
ouais normal et il très magique mais
elle ne connaît pas très bien le rugby
enfin l'important c'est que demain tu
puisses faire un gros match
ah oui avec ce bel équipement je vais
gagner le match
dans un fauteuil formidable quelle
morale casimir didon à quelle place joue
rapidement les devants à l'avant
félicitations qui signe aussi très
courageux de sa part
à l'avant c'est là que le jeu est le
plus rude en rugby non mais je ne joue
pas à l'avant je joue devant à casimir
sur le terrain c'est la même chose mais
non ça n'a rien à voir non feinte
casimir tu viens de me dire que demain
il gagnera ce match devant et dans un
fauteuil
c'est ça je joue devant mon poste de
télévision est assis dans un bon
fauteuil
casimir malo
[Musique]